I'm good nice to see you thank you good
to see you Tom so I got to see the 30
minute extra the making of the movie and
one of the things that I completely
didn't realize because it was so well
done
were the the lane was pret was built on
a soundstage yeah and it looks in the
movie it looks like it's you're filming
on location oh good that's exactly so my
thing though is talk a little bit about
putting together these sets because they
really do look like they're in real life
well I have to I have the greatest team
I have to say John Mayer who was a
production designer and diva who's shot
it really helped integrate our live
action and and you know we were on
location with with all over London but
in addition to that we were also on
stages as well so we found ourselves you
know trying to incorporate that all make
it look very much like one fluid place
and Cherry Tree Lane you know it's
almost impossible to find that kind of
location in London so we built it and
it's so great to actually be here at the
Disney Studios because it was all shot
their first film was all shot here on
all sound stages and that's one of the
things we tried to do was to to bring
some more reality to it because we're
shooting you know in the 30s that was
the intention to create a sort of a very
real place in juxtaposition with the
adventures one of the things that I
always find disappointing is the
Hollywood spend so much time and money
building these incredible practical sets
and then they're just gone no and have
you ever had a conversation with like a
studio saying you know we spent all this
time and money building Cherry Tree Lane
can we put it somewhere you know what it
makes me so sad I feel this exactly the
same way you do but you know it they
just they're not built to last you know
they're built to sort of be up there for
a little bit and then they and don't
don't last and but it was very sad to me
I mean we actually tore down Cherry Tree
Lane while we were filming and reused
that soundstage for the whole Big Bend
sequence at the end so you know you
repurpose stages and it's just it's but
it's it's it's heartbreaking completely
it's breaking especially when you see
that the level of detail that went into
build the
yes it's it hurts um I've spoken to a
lot of filmmakers who you know they have
to finish the film and they're rushing
to make the release date and then
they're doing the blu-ray and they'll
make a slight tweak on a shot or two
that they just were never happy with did
you do that for this film you know what
I didn't have to because we were so
meticulous with it when we worked on the
color work all the visual effects work
we were very very specific about the
look I mean we went through it many many
times myself and Dion Beebe our
cinematographer we were so clear about
you know what we wanted and and so it
actually transferred beautifully so
that's it's lucky I know there's a lot
of fans of this film that cannot wait to
own the blu-ray and watch it on digital
what are you most excited for people to
see in terms of the extras I guess the
the sort of the grand making of there's
a 22-minute making of and it encompasses
all of it you know you see you get a
full sense of the of how we started
where we began I mean there's wonderful
little vignettes about each individual
song which are it's really exciting but
the grand one is the you know is sort of
the making of there's some great things
there's a deleted song that we had which
is really fun there is also a wonderful
vignette and about a little featurette
about Dick Van Dyke so there's a lot on
there which is really great you bring up
Dickie Van Dyke and I totally want to
talk about getting to you got to have
him in the film what is it like how did
you manage to pull it off was it one of
these things were you called and as a
huge fan of the original Mary Poppins
what is that phone call like for you oh
my gosh I mean it was a dream come true
I mean he is honestly my hero and so to
be able to work with him on this was a
dream come true and I when I when I
called him I really wanted him to
understand how much I loved his work and
loved him and and and he was so gracious
I mean an immediately disarming made you
feel you know special and he's funny and
quick and smart and and I will say he
took me by the hand as we walked onto
the set the first time and he said to me
I feel the same spirit here as I did in
the first film and that was
that wasn't the greatest compliment ever
is it one of those things as you he's
obviously placed a very critical role in
the third act you know small but
critical role yes these are ever in your
mind are you thinking I want to work
with him more let's find some more stuff
to film with them well you know I was
just so thrilled to be able to do that
sequence with him I never thought should
there be more I mean you wait the whole
film then he arrives he does that
incredible dance which everybody says to
me is that him you know dancing on that
desk and I said well of course good you
see it's him I guess people can't
believe that he can do that and he was
91 at the time he's now 93 it's and he's
he's astonishing he's an astonishing man
because he lives the message of the film
which is finding the child inside and
living with that sensibility every day
and that's what he does you know he he's
such a bright light and and leads with
joy and Wonder I would imagine before
filming began you there were so many
challenges to make this film come alive
music all the different things what was
the thing that you were maybe most
nervous about or dreading to film
because of the technical challenges I
think the animation live-action sequence
was the scariest because of all the
complexities of working with animators
we had to do it very specifically you
know shot by shot it's all being hand
drawn we actually had three layers which
we went through which is shooting the
entire sequence with animation reference
dancers and our principals then you take
the dancers out and just shoot the
principals emily and lynn for instance
and that wonderful song covers not the
book and then you shoot just the
animation reference dancers and actors
that helps the animators when they're
drunk so there's there's so many layers
to that and it's the first thing we shot
we got there and we said let's start
with the animation sequence because we
needed to deliver all that material to
these wonderful artists and i'm glad we
did it first because it sort of got
everybody together and you know and it
was it was challenging for sure um thank
you so much for your time thank you rats
on everything thank you
you